jacques chirac est au bénin où il
participe au 6e sommet des pays
francophones 47 au total
l'occasion pour le président français de
lancer l'appel de cotonou pour inciter
ses homologues à combattre je cite le
risque de l'uniformité linguistique et
donc culturelle dans le monde
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
philippe harrouard jean cornu il existe
un hymne à la francophonie qui chante
ses petits béninois pour la réunion des
47 chefs d'état ayant en commun l'usagé
du français sur les cinq continents
premier exercice du genre pour jacques
chirac y retrouve entre autres ses amis
afrique une communauté de 130 millions
d'habitants qui entend jouer un rôle
culturel mais aussi politique pour le
maintien de la paix pour tous la défense
du français se joue sur les autoroutes
de l'information
cet échange interplanétaire dominé par
l'anglais
au programme encore la solidarité des
plus riches envers les plus pauvres
pour jacques chirac c'est un devoir même
s'il faut ajuster les besoins à nos
moyens les fonds que nous destinons à
l'action francophones ne seront pas
amputer je m'y engage devant vous et
ceci sans rien enlever et ceci bien sûr
sans rien enlever à l'aide bilatérale ou
multilatérale que la france accorde ses
partenaires des moins favorisés
les difficultés sociales en france n'ont
pas conduit le président chirac a
modifié son programme au bénin
la france a également un rôle
international à jouer nous dit-on qui a
des répercussions sur son image sur son
commerce donc sur l'emploi
une stratégie qu'il ne faut pas négliger
le temps 1 2